light is a full piece and eric acey
continues blitzing actually yeah
i wonder if this will just now be a draw
because rook g8 king e7 rook d5 king f8
yes i i also have the same feeling
because also i mean cornet yeah he's a
25 50 player
the the team kept thinking could have
easily taught him you know what you you
test elegancy and if he knows his stuff
then then draw is fine yeah
yeah and it does look like uh yeah this
is just uh this is going to be the first
game to finish in the round because if
white doesn't play rugged check here
you're just a yeah it's all it's
actually on the board or then yeah yeah
i you know i can see people signing it's
it's even on our screen that the people
are signing uh sky and signing
scoresheets and
yeah where yeah this is this is more
than chess yeah sometimes the more sharp
is the most brilliant craziest ideas and
in a draw because computers just now to
analyze it the the players have to be
prepared they have to know their stuff
and basically both sides can leave with
the result